[Music]
[Applause]
he is Albert Breer the peripatetic
Albert Breer senior NFL reporter he's
the Monday Morning Quarterback he joins
us now where are you right now Albert I
feel like I have to apologize because
this is like an awfully big letdown
after last week I am in the uh waiting
room at a car dealership get my oil
changed so all right I'm not on vacation
anymore I'm not on vacation anymore I'm
but this is all the stuff I have to do
before I leave for Camp because I'll be
gone for most of the next month okay
let's uh let's guess let's play the what
kind of car does Albert Breer oh now I'm
going to sound like such a douche
that's a big hint okay
I like it okay that might change my
answer Todd Nissan Sentra Nissan Sentra
oh that's not it no it can't be a with
that okay Seton oh man this is uh
uh oh you said oil change so it can't be
an electric car
how about uh Porsche no it'd be a poor
shot a Porsche sorry sorry that's a
great question Porsche Cayenne more
scissors that's a great car yes they are
Marvin Range Rover Range Rover Polly I
gotta stick with that I was you know
Albert's Northeast I knew all-wheel
drive would be in his repertoire but I'm
also going Range Rover
range based off his hint
okay
I I uh I'm gonna I'm gonna go with the
Range Rover too
and here we go with the great reveal
Albert Greer the Monday Morning
Quarterback drives
a BMW
nice all right Range Rover Range Rover
was close though I think that's in the
same like douche category right like so
I feel like you guys are in the
neighborhood that's great see it we we
also have a Tahoe so like if I was in
the Chevy dealership I would have been
much more relatable okay right yeah
right you're right so you're right he
earnings everything Peter King that's
probably what he drives he's more
relatable than you
uh I'm not it's unfortunate again
timing's everything all right the Jets
and hard knocks the Jets don't want to
cooperate and let you uh yeah you know
show these guys getting cut well that's
30 of Hard Knocks is those those moments
where these guys get brought in and they
get cut now
can the Jets say to Hard Knocks we're
not going to let the cameras in
uh like to a certain degree yes you know
I I've talked to coaches and general
managers who have been through this and
I believe it it airs on Tuesday nights
right on Monday night they'll get a copy
of it and they'll be able to look
through it and they'll be able to take
out what they want to take out and
sometimes you know I I know there are
cases where coaches and general managers
have pulled that lever and said I don't
want this or this or this in there I
don't think it's all that common
um because one thing I would say is the
film's people are pretty good you know
and and I think and I know you've
probably dealt with them over the years
DP is they have a good way about them
about you know as much as they need and
as many cameras as are going to be there
they do their best they make the best
effort to try to be flies in the wall
you know and try to be out of the way
and you know the people who are on the
ground you know and I know a few of them
worked with some of those guys at NFL
Network are good people and
um generally you know they've been
through this so they're able to build
relationships where and by the time you
go to air which is two and a half weeks
into Camp they've built that level of
trust where coaches and GMS are willing
to work with them on stuff you know but
this is a different situation you know I
mean this is the first time where they
don't have a volunteer they've got a
hostage and um you know I know one of
the things the Jets had sort of
discussed in the spring when this came
up was you know how they're already sort
of a capacity from a media standpoint
with everything that Aaron Rodgers is
going to bring along with them with
everything that you know all the hype
around them is going to bring with it
like they feel like between the amount
of media that's going to be going
through there over the three or four
weeks of Camp between you know the the
in-house stuff that they've got to do
um you know and then just locally the
amount of people that are going to be
there locally
um they're going to be a capacity and um
you know I I think it's going to make
for an interesting few weeks and the
other thing that's interesting is like
the next like week or two should be you
know pretty fascinating as well because
normally if you look at it like the
lions that Hard Knocks was announced on
March 28th I believe of last year
normally
Hard Knocks goes in HBO and films go in
in the spring in May and June to collect
all the b-roll and do all the background
work and everything else well they don't
have that done now
so you know I mean to make the show sing
like it normally sings they're going to
have to get pretty intensive over the
next you know week or two and that of
course could lead to you know some
friction between the crew and the team
can live Shriver
voice something scripted
as an actor with what's going on with
the writer's strike
I don't know I'm not up to date on that
one so
you you know more about that than me I'm
not sure I I didn't even know that's the
first I've heard that that could be a
factor but that's really interesting
yeah well it's a scripted show yeah and
then he voices it but I was just curious
if he's able to yeah you know what when
we get off this column I'm actually
gonna maybe make okay phone calls and
figure that out because I I hadn't
thought about that but that's a good
point and I hadn't you know that
obviously you know would seem to be
another hurdle that they'd have to clear
here and what's going to be
um you know potentially a Summer full of
them the uh the Hard Knocks crew tweet
that came out Veteran running backs are
organizing a group a text chain and I
guess they're commiserating with one
another I I don't know
how do running backs get paid or why do
we care if they get paid or they don't
get paid
I think you know there's a human element
to it of course right like which is
these guys take an absolute beating you
know and they are valuable the problem
they have that there's a few problems I
I would say like about four problems
here number one their Prime happens
during the rookie contracts right like
whereas with a receiver or a pass rusher
or a tackle or certainly a quarterback
like they're just hitting their Primus
they come out of their rookie contracts
Like You could argue running backs like
the heart of their Prime is during that
rookie contract and it played out in
cases like Todd Gurley and Ezekiel
Elliott where the team's got the best
years when those guys were under cost
control you know so what everybody's
fighting for
um in the NFL which is to get to a
second contract it's much harder for a
running back because you're not paying
for past performance you're paying for
future performance and history shows us
that the best performance that they're
going to have after four or five years
is their past performance
um the franchise tag is a problem
because it's so affordable right like
and if you look at that you say it's not
a smart investment to invest in a sixth
and seventh year for a running back
um with the pounding that they take
um then they a team can very easily look
at that and say we'd rather just go year
to year with you so the franchise Tag's
a problem because it's so affordable and
such an easy mechanism for teams not to
commit long-term to these guys is the
repeat then give me a solution give me a
solution here that everybody I don't
know you know what one of the biggest
problems is Dan is like how replaceable
they are you know like look in the Super
Bowl like that's the issue it's not that
saquon Barkley or Josh Jacobs or Tony
Paul aren't excellent players they're
all really good players it's well like
what if I do let this go go this guy go
like when negotiations get tough it's
like okay like so like what's behind
door number two and then you look at the
two teams in the Super Bowl and the
Chiefs starting running back in the
Super Bowl was a seventh round rookie
Isaiah Pacheco and the Eagles starting
running back was Miles Sanders who was
on a rookie contract and after the
season they let him go for just over six
million dollars a year in free agency
right so what does that tell you I you
know I think that's the problem is it's
not that these guys aren't great players
it's the teams are looking at it and
saying it's much easier for me to fill
this position than it would be for me to
find a great receiver or to find a great
corner you know the same thing sort of
exists on the offensive line but that's
why tackles get paid right like I can't
I can find a guard I can find a center
it's really hard to find a great left
tackle right in a secondary I can find a
great corner or I can find a great
safety I can find a good safety I could
be good enough there it's really hard to
find a great corner so I think that
that's a huge part of it and I think
that that's why
as long as there are so many options for
teams out there to fill the position in
different ways like what are you gonna
do like the Rams like right like the
Rams have been a big part of this
because they pivoted halfway through
that building process to really focus on
building around premium positions right
so they focused on Corners Jalen Ramsey
pass rushers Aaron Donald tackles Andrew
Whitworth receivers Cooper cop
quarterback obviously Matthew Stafford
and they went to a Super Bowl talk early
and lost they come back a couple years
later they weren't near as good at
running back right in 2021 as they were
in 2018 but they won the Super Bowl so
that's the issue I think is it it just
becomes too replaceable and I think one
thing that's highlighted that certainly
is Analytics right because now it's not
teams just like looking at it based on
their own experience they've got like
numbers to quantify all of this as well
and so you know I I think the
replaceability factor is a is a really
really big one here he's Albert Breer
joining us uh from some car dealership
getting his BMW's oil change he is the
Monday Morning Quarterback that's of
course what you would expect the Monday
Morning Quarterback to drive
um
Belichick and the hot seat yeah real or
fabricated
I don't
I don't think he'll get fired
um
it's just like I think Robert Kraft
would pursue something different than
that if he were trying to push him out
now I don't know Bill could force him to
fire him
um I think they need to show progress
though for there not to be some level of
shake-up and you know I I think like
you're starting to see a like a level of
discomfort with the crafts on where they
are and some of the statements that
Robert Craft has made over the last
couple of years
um and and look like I think if you look
at where they are now versus 2019 it's
hard to say they're not on an upward
trajectory and then if you look it's
like how many players in the roster can
you say are going to be there three
years from now right like where this guy
is a good enough player where I know
he's going to be there in three years
like say Garrett Wilson or sauce Gardner
are for the Jets right like that guy's
gonna be there so I think as much as
winning and losing this year is going to
be about showing but they have to be bad
to get better from the standpoint of
getting dropped the Jets were bad and
got those draft picks the Patriots are
average
they struck out on a lot of draft picks
too though and that's the thing is and I
I understand what you're saying is like
are they stuck in that like you know
you're the 45 when NBA team like that
thing right like where you know you're
you're good enough to be competitive but
not good enough to get over the top
um you know but I think that's a big
part of it is finding creative ways to
show your on an upward trajectory right
and like I I think if you look at the
roster there are some good young players
on that but Kyle Duggar Joshua like are
these Michael wino like are these guys
that you're gonna be they're gonna be
cornerstones for you for the next decade
you know like I I don't know and then
there's the quarterback question so like
I think I think the crafts are concerned
about the direction of the franchise
especially after what they went through
last year on the coaching staff right
and I think like bill needs to show that
they are back on the way up again
because this is the fourth year without
Brady right so we've gone through like
almost like a whole cycle of rookies and
all of that like since Brady has been
gone so they need to show like bill
needs to show we're on an upward
trajectory to prevent there being some
level of change for the second straight
year in the organization and I think
where you could see this right like the
way I see it like barring like a
bottoming out where they're four and 13
or something
what if Robert Kraft wants to hire a GM
what if Robert Kraft wants changes on
the coaching staff he did this year or
if he wants to do that again
is that the type of thing where it makes
Belichick throw his hands up and say the
hell with this I'm out you know like so
but they're not helping Mac Jones that
if you look at what the Dolphins did
with Tua the Eagles did with Jalen hurts
Mac Jones I don't know if he's a good
quarterback or not but if I put him in
Miami or put him in Philadelphia I guess
he's going to be a whole lot better than
he is in New England and you're at least
gonna have Clarity right like and that's
the question and I think like the
problem the big the fundamental problem
here Dan is they're building like it's
still 10 years ago they're building like
they still have Tom Brady and if you
look at the roster there are a whole
bunch of good players but how many great
players do they have and the way the
league is going you see teams that are
built around great players and making it
work everywhere else right like the best
teams now have great players at premium
positions and make it work everywhere
else the Patriots aren't like that the
Patriots are trying to build on balance
again which when you have Tom Brady that
works because he can lift all boats
right look at the off season two years
ago right so they went in to brought
these guys and Matthew judon on defense
really worked but on offense they
brought in Nelson Aguilar and Kendrick
Bourne at receiver and they brought in
Hunter Henry Johnny Smith at tight end
meanwhile other teams instead of going
for three or four guys were making the
splash like you said AJ Brown to Philly
Devonte Adams to Vegas Tyree Tyree
killed in Miami and I think what we've
seen is like it really helps your Young
quarterback more than anything else to
get the guy who changes the dynamic for
everybody right and
um you know like Patrick Mahomes had
that in in Tyreek Hill when he was young
now tuatanga below is getting it with
Hill and waddle like you said Jalen
hurts has gotten it with AJ Brown
in Buffalo Stefan Diggs was traded for
three years into Josh Allen's career
you're gonna have some big decisions to
make on Matt Jones
um after this year on the fifth year
option whether to extend him all of that
whether to go after another quarterback
after this year and I think my biggest
question would be whether or not they've
done enough to give themselves Clarity
on that like like you said are you going
to be able to get yourself closer to a
clear answer on whether he's the guy or
not based on what you've put around him
and the idea that that might not happen
as a result of the way they've built the
team
yeah I think what we're finding out is
players will go to New England if they
can win a Super Bowl and you have Tom
Brady players aren't looking to go to
New England just to say I played for
Bill Belichick uh right it's great to
see are there other people in the
waiting room there
I don't know I'll text you after and
I'll we'll figure that out okay I guess
somebody knocked on the door right
before I came in but I didn't hear
because I'm oblivious to everything they
must be wondering what you're doing in
there you're talking to yourself there
but uh well like I like I said like I
said this has got to be like the biggest
step down in the history of the show
when it comes to backdrop from last week
to this week right yeah yeah the water
behind you and now you got a pale
looking wall and I think there's a
mechanic walking around behind you there
well hey over the next few weeks you
know if you guys want to uh check out
like what Marriott backdrops look like
I'll be able to I'll be able to help you
guys out there yeah uh thanks for
joining us as always Albert all right
thanks Dan that's Albert Breer he is the
Monday Morning Quarterback and he's just
like you and me he gets his oil changed